si lo he recibido positivamente la
propuesta China para Ucrania porque
contiene reflexiones útiles para
conseguir la paz china por su parte
agradecido los esfuerzos de Brasil para
solucionar el conflicto eso reza el
comunicado conjunto emitido a bien
entrada la noche y después de la reunión
entre sí sin Pin y Lula da silvanspartes
también animan a otros países a sumarse
a los esfuerzos tanto china como Brasil
se han postulado como mediadores en la
guerra china lo ha hecho con un plan de
12 puntos que pide el inmediato alto el
fuego Sin condiciones previas Brasil por
su parte con la creación de un grupo de
países neutrales en el que además de
Brasil y China también estarían India o
Indonesia que empujarían a la mesa de
negociaciones a Rusia y Ucrania ambos
planes han sido ignorados tanto por
Estados Unidos como por Europa que
defienden la propuesta de zelnesky como
la única vía de solución al conflicto
esta Cumbre ha subrayado la creciente
brecha entre occidente y el mundo
emergente seguro que no habrá gustado en
Estados Unidos porque Brasil se ha
alineado en varios asuntos con china
Lula visitó la sede de la tecnológica
china Huawei fuertemente sancionada por
Estados Unidos y también la sede del
banco de los brics o economías
emergentes donde lanzó una andanada
tremenda contra la hegemonía del dólar
en el mundo se preguntó por qué no
podían elegir una divisa diferente para
sus intercambios comerciales Lula antes
de reunirse con sí prometió que ningún
país iba a prohibir a Brasil que
siguiera mejorando sus relaciones con
China